[Music]
everybody is buzzing about Wendy
Williams suddenly fainting and the
middle of her talk show and the clip
went viral instantly it was a
frightening moment to watch her collapse
on live TV today Wendy was very
emotional as she explained what happened
I'm feeling like hot and a little dizzy
our first caress that's when you saw me
with the eyes because I wasn't it was
skipped it it was scare we overcome with
a wave of emotion while detailing her
terrifying on-air feint Wendy explains
what viewers didn't see once the show
quickly cut to commercial
oh it's chaos behind the scenes I'm on
the floor but I'm just hold I was only
down for three seconds and that next
thing I know my husband comes out and
you know collects me and brings me
backstage a team of paramedics
ultimately determined Wendy lacked
essential electrolytes due to
dehydration but a production source
tells et staff members are concerned
that the stress of an alleged affair by
her husband of nearly 20 years Kevin
hunter is taking its toll in September
Daily Mail TV reported Kevin was
allegedly carrying on a 10-year affair
with 32 year-old massage therapist
Serena Hudson they aired this photo of
them together in New Jersey you can
believe what you want but Wendy took to
her show days later slamming the
allegations don't believe the hype and
if there was hype believe me you I would
let you know and Wendy has been open to
et in the past
she says he cheated on her years ago and
forgave him infidelity does not always
mean you throw it out and sometimes it
can strengthen relationships our source
tells ET that when it comes to the
latest report quote this is so
catastrophic for her at the end of the
day the bottom line is that we all want
Wendy to be healthy yeah we certainly
wish her the very very best
[Music]
you